no one should be for this if you are
remotely principled and you're on MSNBC
jansaki or Joy Reed or anyone else stand
up against this you have a moment to do
the right thing I know it's not like in
your skill set but you might be able to
do the right thing right now you might
be able to if you're Jake Tapper over on
CNN or one of these other people to to
Really uh talk about what principles
actually are
but we all know the Trump derangement
syndrome is one of the things that
breaks principles and these people
aren't very good at it uh here is uh New
Hampshire Governor Chris sununu
silencing Jake Tapper over the Trump
prosecution which he views as unfair and
unjust because he's right
I can tell you I think it's building a
lot of Sympathy for the former president
I think the fact that I was with coffee
this morning with some folks and and
there's ever not none of them were big
Trump supporters but they all said uh
you know they felt like he was being
attacked and as you pointed out this is
likely some sort of misdemeanor on an
issue seven years ago this has nothing
to do with January 6th there's folks out
there that still think this has
something to do with with January 6th so
um I just think that the the not just
the media but really A lot of the
Democrats have misplayed this in terms
of building Sympathy for the former
president and it does drastically change
the Paradigm as we go into the 24
election
dude who's absolutely right I've been a
little critical of sununu on the show
because I I think he's one of those
Republicans that can't accomplish
anything really so that's why he's put
on CNN but he did do a nice job there
Tapper looks like like he was on a
bender all night or he just can't deal
sometimes you know the thing is if you
lie all the time uh eventually it starts
bursting forth and he just looks
absolutely exhausted
um but one of the things that I often
talk about is Democrat privilege right
so if you're a Democrat you can get away
with anything you can fund the the uh
the Steele dossier if you're Hillary
Clinton and you can get away with it you
can call Trump an illegitimate president
you can get away with it you can lie
about absolutely everything because
there's an entire corporate machine
based in protecting your lives
laundering through them through the
system right we leak something to the
New York Times CNN covers the New York
Times article the thing was leaked off a
dossier that was fabricated and paid for
by a candidate but you can do all that
if you're a Democrat and get away with
it if you're a republican obviously you
can't you get these crazy Soros back
DA's going after you for as sununu said
um misdemeanor about seven years ago
right it's just all nonsense right it's
just complete nonsense
[Music]
foreign